hello guys I'm Ryan right hi guys I'm
Veronica six dos we're gonna check out
today from zero Fox FK unexplained top
six real disturbing ghosts caught on
tape very creepy footage of the
paranormal this better be real stuff
hoping it's real the same time I don't
want to
right so here we have the living room
area so far it's quite small kitchen
hallway where poster this stuff happens
we'll turn on a lot dark now I don't buy
it
nah I don't know scary stuff
[ __ ] all
out of here oh stop
suspensful that woman
zero to the camcorder I had that night
vision that was [ __ ] epic
why don't they show more event these are
fake
that one seemed real especially cuz that
guy's reaction
yeah I don't know about the other ones
with that last one looked very real like
especially cuz the way the guy reacted
to that I got chills yeah I got chills
ooh Oh baby feel this nipple chills oh
yeah you know that's how the video was
effective right there have you ever seen
it ghost in the first house that I moved
into when we moved to LA we listened to
a voicemail and there was so normal
person leaving a voicemail and then
suddenly that person got cut off no
longer heard that person's voice I went
silent and staticky and then you heard a
voice a different voice mail say get out
he said something like get out of my
home no lie absolutely no lie every one
of my family heard it my dad is harder
to convince he believed it he listened
to it was scared shitless and we decided
let's not talk about it because we don't
want to welcome the spirit that's pretty
and there was another time that I was on
my bed with my dog Hershey I was you
know reading a book or something and
erotica yeah I was in my bedroom light
was on bedroom door was closed
then Hershey the dog started to growl
and he was looking at something I was
sitting in the middle of my bed he was
looking this way and slowly his eyes
followed something all the way around
across on around to the other side of
the bed he's growling and then all of a
sudden his growling gets even more
intense like he was ready to pounce like
whatever it was he was seeing was
getting closer onto the bed and then I
started praying and it went away what if
it was a really small fly
oh no dia was a ghost it was for sure
ghost for sure was it good six credit
just been like a little bug no you don't
understand he was it was very very slow
started here and he was obviously
threatened when a dog doesn't trust you
and how it responds to you and it's
looking at you it growls at you and it
follows you around very cautiously
that's what he was doing one time in my
old house there was I was cleaning
dishes and in the kitchen it leads to
the back door said there was a door then
a screen door and the door was opened
the screen door was closed I hear a
noise outside I turn around and there's
just this guy's face and then it turns
away it ended up being my Tarzan balloon
so it wasn't a ghost that the closest
it's the closest I've ever gotten an
account seeing a ghost was mistaking my
Disney's Tarzan balloon actually now I
talked about this in another video I
tried being a devoted Catholic when I
was young and don't you ever yawn in the
middle of me talking I tried being a
devoted Catholic when I was really young
Passion of the Christ really inspired me
and for a solid three weeks I was really
insane was really into it I went to
Catholic school and then there was a
church right next door to us and after
school I decided to go to church and
pray because I thought that would do
something good then one day I went in
there and it's always empty in there was
always empty like no one was there no
one's going to church at 3:30 in the
afternoon on Tuesday all of a sudden I
hear this like this voice that sounds
really close to me just go it sounds
like a little girl just go hello and it
sounded like clothes I felt I heard an
echo really and then I was I just said I
was scared and I just went hello just
trying to get a reaction out of whoever
said that and no one responded and I
think it was a little black girl
just her voice she's black her voice I
just got this image of a little black
girl with brains interesting yeah maybe
she was maybe or I'm just a racist Resta
that's sure enough a little black girl
part you know my dad passed away a
couple years ago and I still have dreams
about today and it's one of those things
where you're like I don't know is a
trauma based or is my dad trying to talk
to me you know what is it exactly so I
don't know exactly what ghosts are I
don't know exactly what the paranormal
stuff is you could tell me all kinds of
stuff at the end of the day I don't know
exactly what the [ __ ] it is but I do
believe they're real thank you yeah I
believe they're very real I believe I
believe your spirit is an energy that
like can move on and move forward and I
don't know I kind of under this
impression that you could either choose
to stay on earth or you could go to
heaven her I don't really believe in
hell but sometimes we do get really
fiery in bed what does that have to do
and just saying we create hell in the
bedroom my mom's mom died when she was
26 or 27 something like that and um she
used to have a lot of incidences where
she would hear things or things would
change in the house and there was one
time where she walked into her mother's
bedroom she was passing by the closet
and an envelope fell out of the closet
inside the envelope was a letter written
by her mother saying how when she died
she wanted to be cremated her dad knew
that his wife wanted to be cremated but
they didn't end up cremating her they
buried her so after she died this happen
my mom reads the letter and it was
obviously her mom trying to send her a
message about it so like lots of things
like that happened to her and one time
in her dream one time in her dream her
mom was coming towards her like wanting
to embrace her and that kept floating
towards her kept floating towards her
and my mom was
pushing her away pushing her away saying
no mom no it's time I need to let you go
I need to let you go finally she
actually stopped getting those those um
visits from her mom they like all the
incidents has stopped after she had that
dream
if you guys are new to the channel you
can click this button to subscribe come
a reject the order today
Veronica has a channel acoustic covers
and originals they do and she is
currently in a contest make me famous
taught us going on right now around to
voting polls for round two closed
tomorrow so you better get your votes in
please obviously put together a sketch a
horror comedy sketch that's in between
takes with Ryan and brandy but Veronica
is one of the main supporting characters
in it too he had gotta find out what she
does in it she's getting the most
comments Victor a Rea SC hive a big fan
really love your show I'd really
appreciate a shadow shape shadow thanks
keep up the great work
Victor I love that you love this show
show is everything to me
Victor I just want to share this with
you yeah
everything I did was to make you happy
wasn't even for me it's for you
here I cry don't do it Victor one way to
break character Veronica hmm what if we
were filming would you do that to an
acting Barbie
you're really crying right now yeah you
know you always forget how talented I am
you dramatic chops it's hot I was
covering up a yawn